there was truck you know Trump's wall it
wasn't finished in certain spots
so the current the governor who's going
out put in uh containers to for as a
stop Gap
and they basically they it worked
foreign
it opens up to more Farm ground for them
to walk across
I was glad that they came in because
then it helped funnel the people to a
certain location to where then the
border patrol could
um
manage them easier when they had all
these holes in it there was multiple
places where these people would come
across and it was a lot harder on the
border patrol to actually
pick them up in an orderly fashion
there was a process for them where they
were being funneled down to one point
where border patrol can can manage it
now you now those containers are gone I
don't know why it was working it wasn't
bothering the farmers it wasn't
bothering anybody that lives on the
border because it doesn't affect them
and uh they're gone
in one day
they told me that they're going to start
construction on filling the gaps this
week and so if they do that
then it all be worth getting rid of them
and if there's that many construction
people down there hopefully we won't
have
as many people coming across just
because there's so much action down
there
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
what's the point it's working
so it's effective it's working why not
is it just ego where it's like oh that's
not our Administration I don't know
there was nothing
impacting the environment in any way
it's that's ridiculous
not going to be confident until I see
the work actually being done
Administration
to me it seems like they want this to
happen and for one reason I do not know
they've got some pretty good Intel into
the Border Patrol
kind of the highest levels and they say
that they've been given the green line
so
we'll
see